[Música]
a
escala en parís ayuda palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 que hoy dedicamos a rusia a sus
servicios secretos y al hombre fuerte
del kremlin vladímir putin con un ex
agente del café de el único espía ruso
que integró la escuela nacional de la
administración francesa para infiltrarse
entre las élites políticas y que además
durante su trayectoria se cruzó en
varias ocasiones con putin hoy hace
escala en parís ser gays y no ser gay
muchísimas gracias por volver a estar
con nosotros
bueno pues usted es ex espía ruso
periodista y especialista en relaciones
internacionales y acaba de publicar este
libro legado junto al autor sanlúcar
arriba
editorial libros legados que a lo mejor
podríamos traducir en español como el
pionero como el que va de la nasa de
ella como el explorador no los scouts
scouts efectivamente y se trata de una
biografía en la que explica a través de
500 páginas su vida desde el
reclutamiento por el café hasta su
exilio en francia pasando por sus
operaciones como ilegal ex espía a quien
en francia y en este libro hay varios
pasajes sobre vladimir putin el
presidente ruso quien fue también
miembro de los servicios secretos
como usted y se acuerda muy bien de la
primera vez que se encontraron estamos
en el año
1980 año de los juegos olímpicos en
moscú y ese primer encuentro es un
interrogatorio
claro a
un estudiante de instituto de relaciones
internacionales en moscú es una escuela
muy muy famosa abajo la otan de
ministerio de asuntos exteriores
a trabajar como un voluntario como un
intérprete durante los juegos olímpicos
en un centro o en servicios de
telefónico de información
en lenguas extranjeras por mí en francés
en esa época
tuve una conversación con un francés
durante dos horas
eso parecía a mi dirección y a los
servicios secretos rusos como muy
sospechoso sospechaban que era un
disidente un espía para los franceses y
pues después de esta conversación yo fue
como fui convocado en la oficina de la
directora de ese centro en la oficina y
encontré con un hombre un pequeño
hombre en
quien me presentó su carta roja y su
carta roja del café y fue el capitán
vladimir putin qué sensación le dio
una sensación era insignificante era era
nadie efecto en ese
traje muy pequeño pero con su carta en
el ggb ello yo sentí que tenía el poder
del canje y le gustaba le gustaba
detenerse su poder porque me pidió
li
que lo siguiera en la sede del café vea
plaza lubyanka en mente erogó durante
dos horas porque a esta época no eres
pío
no no no era
no no lo voy a hacer a ser uno
y
durante nueve años él entró en encaje en
1975 al en grano y fue a su servicio
durante 99 años en la policía política
del canje ve en el contraespionaje y en
1984 el mismo año que yo entró en la
academia en la ciudad andrópov el que
formaba a los espías y soñaba
será ser un espía
pero nunca lo fue la gente lo fue porque
los instructores de ese instituto
creían que era peligroso usted dice que
es insignificante que es muy inseguro
que tiene incluso complejo de
inferioridad sin embargo lleva 20 años
dirigiendo rusia a lo tiene que tener
paradoja paradoja paradoja es un
paradoja porque
porque putin en efecto
al primero fue un marioneta para el
familia de
esa familia tiene el 6 que acaba
sobre putin porque pensaban que era una
marioneta que podemos manejarlo
simplemente fácilmente en efecto putin a
término para manejar a sus manejadores
putin
también
correspondía perfectamente a la imagen
del presidente que rusia a espectar que
que el pueblo ruso espectador durante 30
años porque no amaba no amaba a los
dirigentes como habréis nyt corbacho
fiel sin etcétera por eso alguien nuevo
hecho a sí mismas y nuevo joven la bien
no sé a hablar en público no no le no le
gusta hablar de público pero lo hace
bien anule el papel
es esa imagen de también la imagen de
nombre del bosque porque -ha que el café
era el instituto
estatal que era lo menos corrompido que
nosotros en
algunos tratan de loco por haber
invadido a ucrania incluso dicen que es
un paranoico que no se acerca a nadie y
algunos después de haber visto imágenes
dicen que está que está enfermo cuál es
su impresión está loco está enfermo
putin está todo eso
pero no me no me gusta decirlo porque si
lo decimos eso significa que es
irresponsable y está enfermo porque
algunos decían que tenían como la
si durante la comida estaba solo
aislado habíamos visto a cuando emanuel
macrón llegó a moscú era una distancia
de 5 metros de 6 metros y nos parece
completamente loco
una pregunta ese rey putin es capaz de
lanzar una guerra nuclear
y yo creo que sí yo creo que sí
pero yo no creo que ya va a bombardear
no sé france a parís
washington u otras filas ciudades
capitalidad de los países capitalistas
pero puede hacerlo en ucrania porque a
mi juicio fútil no puede ganar esta
guerra con la ucrania con las armas
clásicas con las armas convencionales
está perdiendo la guerra porque se
retiró de que deja channing de acs hoy
día que se retire de jarque
en un caso cuando los ucranianos
apoyados por los estados unidos apoyados
por el excedente con las armas
más
avanzarán más avanzadas que ya que las
armas soviéticas que pudiera adquirir
sepas que porque pueden utilizar las
armas soviéticas
puede ser lo mismo lo mismo que
americanos nacieron en 1945 cuando
decían ah no perdimos seis meses para
ganar la guerra contra los controles
japoneses
hacemos 2
bombardeos atómicos eso eso es la fin de
la guerra pudding puede ser hacer la
misma cosa en ucrania para usted
entonces quienes estaban dando la guerra
es ucrania o está resistiendo o no la
está ganando nadie a mi juicio
putin perdió y saquear
en febrero y en febrero porque todo no
se pasó como putin pensaba a esta guerra
la rusia es una o todo todos decían el
ejército ruso es el segundo ejército en
el mundo poderoso etcétera etcétera
en realidad
vimos que no hacen nada que aquí que
están están perdiendo la guerra y
ucrania a mi juicio sola ucraniano pueda
no podía ganar esta guerra pero apoyada
actualmente por pues podría ser todo el
mundo no toda la china o india nos
están apoyando pero el occidente apoya a
ucrania
64 mil millones de dólares de ayuda
militar de ayuda humanitaria de ayuda
financiera eso es una ayuda muy
importante y ucranianos sobre y nos
defienden a los territorios a sus
territorios a sus países y el ejército
ruso para eso es un ejército que son
traidores por eso a mi juicio porque no
puede ganar control contra el pueblo de
45 millones de personas que defienden su
territorio nos quedaría muy poco tiempo
se nos ha ido volando
pero quería preguntarle a alguien puede
parar a putin porque podemos quedarnos
en esta guerra casi de forma infinita
que se avanza se retrocede
el presidente francés de manuel mccomb
se empleó a fondo para evitar este
conflicto pero no lo consiguió además
hace poco bueno se anunció que rusia
expulsaba 34 diplomáticos franceses hay
algo o alguien que pueda parar esta
guerra
27 diplomáticos españoles y españoles e
italianos
a eso la guerra diplomática es la guerra
de espías es una guerra pico colina es
una guerra es un secreto original que
hay espías en la de las embajadas en
general
esperen un momento un buen momento para
utilizarlo eso no es más importante
pero una
presencia macro no cree que puede hacer
algo
con putin que puede
enfrentar entre 0 a putin
a mi juicio y se equivoca y se equivoca
desde el primer día de su elección en
2017 cuando
recibió a putin ehlers hay un grande
recepción del estado
no no estima a emanuel macrón por eso en
manual cuando no puede hacer nada pues
pero el menor el macro viene evidente
para ahí fue la desde
durante meses los meses de febrero marzo
y abril era un campaña presidencial de
selecciones que utilizaba también con
también
esos ha pillado
llamada llamada este deterioro
telefónicos a putin para usarse
como study funes y una pieza clave en la
geopolítica si sergey shilov se nos ha
terminado el tiempo muchísimas gracias y
espero que algún día les llegaba que
usted ha escrito junto a sally criba
sobre su vida pues lo podamos también
leer en español muchísimas gracias
espero también pero los derechos es muy
bueno pues muchísimas gracias y gracias
a todos ustedes por habernos acompañado
ya saben que nos pueden seguir también
por internet en rf y mundo.com y un
france24 punto com hasta pronto amigos
[Música]